but why are you so sure that there's no
link between enjoying movie violence and
enjoying real violence I don't I I'm
going to tell you why I'm so sure do not
ask me a question like that I'm not
gonna I'm not biting I refuse your
question why because I refuse your
question I'm not your slave and you're
not my master you can't make me dance to
your tune I'm not a monkey I'm not mate
you answer anything I'm just yeah and
I'm saying and I'm saying I refuse it's
interesting that you have a different
View and I'm just trying to explore that
and I don't want to
because I'm here to sell my movie
this is a commercial for the movie make
no mistake no but you you haven't you
haven't fleshed it out it's not my job
to flesh it out no it's my it's my job
to try and ask you to and I'm shutting
your butt down and that's that's
entirely your that's entirely this is a
commercial from my movie but you haven't
said why you think there's no
relationship it's none of your damn
business what I think about that
well it's my job to ask you why you
think you're very important no